[Music]
you cross the globe in search of
adventure with Harrison Ford you watch
Nick Cage save America then Marky Mark
took you to Papa John's I'm literally in
a Papa John's right now I found it
excuse me guys
now follow along with Tom Hanks on
another baffling mystery what's up with
this hair in this wood was that on
purpose is it supposed to be like
professory or The Da Vinci Code
back in 2003 the world Hit the brown
note as Dan Brown plopped out the fakest
story about Da Vinci since Assassin's
Creed II what of the body bring it
inside and put it with the others in a
historical tale that feels like skimming
Wikipedia after six beers with
references to the only three paintings
Americans can name the Mona Lisa the
Vitruvian man I trust you recognize the
Last Supper because they think the only
way you'll care about art history is if
they turn it into an episode of Maury
but how could Christ have a bloodline
unless man he was pregnant at the time
of the crucifixion you are the father
when the curator of the lube gets shot
he'll have just enough time to write a
whole bar trivia night on the walls oh
Draconian devil
ranks rocks Madonna up the rocks
and Googling all of the keywords is Tom
Hanks as Robert Langdon compounding
keywords in London night Pope Grail
follow a hero with zero connection to
any of these people how well did you
know the curator not very well who
mostly just seems annoyed to be there
I've jammed my shoulder I've been shot
at I'm bleeding but since the most
interesting thing about him is that he
fell down a well one time he'll jump at
the chance to lecture a whole new
audience to death her smile is in the
lower spatial frequencies The Horizon is
significantly lower on the left than it
is on the right Priory of Zion is a myth
one of the world's oldest and most
secret societies with leaders like uh
Sir Isaac it all started over a thousand
years ago when a French king conquered
the holy city of Jerusalem this Crusade
10 plus themselves it's named for the
original Rose line Roslyn chance the
pairing of those two pyramids it's
Unique the two are geometric echoes
fascinating pitcher says a thousand
words
but
which words uh how did they make three
of these things journey to Paris whereby
French law Amelie and Leon the
Professional must appear in your film
Jean Reno is fash I'm captain
a police officer but I repeat myself
Audrey tattoo is Sophie the last
ascendant of Jesus Christ according to
her grandfathers definitely not a sex
cold she's inherited her ancestors
powers to heal the uh claustrophobic
maybe you healed my phobia with your
hands knows how to handle a whip
[Applause]
no no you're not gonna make it you're
not gonna make it
and can tolerate men explaining basic
symbols to her even though she's a
police cryptographer it represents
aggression and manhood the simple still
used today in modern military uniforms
yes the more penises you have the higher
your rank patience of a saint thrill as
everyone chases each other around some
of Europe's Most dreary tourist traps
full of weird little creeps like Silas
Paul bedny literally shines as a
modern-day Sith Lord with the strength
to kill anyone from a defenseless old
nun
to a defenseless old man
you know I'd probably take something
crazy like a wheelchair about a guy with
a walking stick to take him out
[Music]
not my body it's my only weakness
so buckle up for a movie that uncovers
the darkest conspiracy in the Catholic
church in second darkest that dresses up
like an action-packed Ted talk but plays
like Indiana Jones stripped of anything
fun or visually interesting
a magic cup The Souls of God's power on
Earth
it's nonsense no time to argue throw me
the idol I throw you the whip
many of our followers are married many
of them have families only a small
proportion choose to live ascetic lives
the library I have to get to a library
fast
starring
you've got Grail what if God was one of
us Reno 911
May pass oh thank you Silas the
violinist the butler did it and Doctrine
octopus
There's Something About Mary
the whole movie revolves around
mistaking PS for princess Sophie and I
can't believe How I Met Your Mother
somehow did it better
[Music]
Paul Shaffer Paul Schaefer hey screen
junkies Indiana Jones is back in
theaters this weekend dust off your
Fedora and study up with the complete
timeline of all his adventures laid out
chronologically in a museum worthy
episode of crime it click the box in the
Roy to watch now
everything the light touches is ours to
honest review I used to be an adventurer
like you then I took an arrow to the
knee
Charlie bit my finger
super toilet ah so much clogging